what's up everybody we just got some
pretty big news for Avengers for just a
fair warning if some of the things that
I think and speculate are correct there
could be potential spoilers for Avengers
sport so now is your chance to click
away
before we get into it Congrats again to
G Ramirez underscore three to three he
was one of the winners of the Blu ray
giveaway that I chose he just received
his copy in the mail and sent me this
picture Congrats again and a reminder
that it still continues if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
all you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so we've been hearing
a lot of thoughts about Avengers 4
reshoots and today we just found out
that john slattery
has been on the set of Avengers 4 which
means Howard Stark will be in Avengers 4
there are two ways that we could see
Howard Stark reappear in Avengers 4 and
one is barf technology barf technology
stands for it by narrowly augmented
retro framing by nearly augmented retro
framing weren't barf god I got to work
on that recommend an extremely costly
method of hijacking the hippocampus to
clear traumatic memories a lot of people
have been thinking that barf technology
is time travel technology and it is not
it doesn't change the fact that they
never made it to the airport or all the
things I did to avoid processing in
Greece
Plus 611 million dollars for my little
therapeutic experiment barf technology
helps the user revisit memories it also
allows the user to alter traumatic
experiences hopefully helping them
overcome them but it does not change
time just your memories
so Tony Stark could revisit the memories
that he has with his dad in search of
something that could help him defeat
Thanos we know that Howard Stark and
Hank Pym used to work together a very
long time ago perhaps Tony at one point
overheard his father Howard Stark speak
about quantum technology and the quantum
realm and the ability to possibly travel
through time it would make sense that
Tony would use Barth technology to try
and revisit a memory of when he heard
his father mentioned time travel so he
himself could try and discover it so
that's one way we could see him but the
second reason is time travel itself
every single thing that we've heard
about Avengers 4 says time travel no
matter what it is whether it's leaked
photos leaked supposed plot leaks
everything points to time travel nothing
has been officially confirmed but
logically it just makes sense
Kevin Feige president of Marvel Studios
did say that ant-man and the wasp
connects directly to Avengers 4 and the
only thing that was really found that
connects ant-man in the wash to Avengers
4 is the mention of a time vortex in the
post-credits scene so maybe Tony Stark
figures time-travel out somehow he
obviously will have to and he goes and
visits a time where his father is alive
there are many reasons for this
there are many past events that Tony
could go back to and change to change
future events not to mention he could go
back and save his parents from being
killed by Bucky Barnes maybe he needs to
go into the past because he heard his
father at one point in time mentioned
the Infinity stones and needs to talk to
him about it to get information like I
said there is a lot of reasons that we
could list of why Tony Stark would go
back in time and visit his father but
whatever reason it is whether he sees
him through barbed technology or he sees
him by going into the past and seeing
him I think this confirms time-travel
yeah it's pretty much been confirmed
before but you never know
with marvel they did a pretty good job
of being pretty sneaky with Avengers
infinity war so I think that this just
helps further prove that there's going
to be time travel in Avengers 4 that's
how they're going to figure out a way to
defeat Thanos but what do you all think
about this let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and again the
giveaway continues if you would like to
enter for your chance to win a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]